this isn't a hospital it's a cage
this movie's been through countless
speed bumps as we talked about
but i know like for me i can't really
even look back at interviews that i did
three years ago because i'm like oh i'm
a totally different person i've grown so
much in that time so
what is it like for you guys looking
back at something that you shot
many years ago my brain literally just
screams baby
like the whole time i'm watching it i'm
like charlie's a baby i'm a baby henry's
a baby like we're all just
children um but to be fair i still feel
like a baby just like slightly more
grown up um so yeah it's an interesting
experience for sure
yeah yeah similar it's a double-edged
sword like you watch it and it's so long
ago that you kind of
yeah you kind of removed from it so it's
almost like not watching yourself but
you are watching yourself
uh because you forgot about you know
what you were going
you know what you were doing at that
time but then yeah at the same time
you're like
yeah it's still you yeah
yeah it's it's kind of easier to watch
it three years later
having some you know separation from it
and then
be able to just sit back and forgive it
a little bit you know the little
in and out to things and uh you know we
were meant to have it
out in april after rapping in november
so i think that would have been harsher
if you're like a
hyper self-critical person like i am
now it's like whoa okay that's like a
different person you know
yeah yeah kind of compartmentalized the
merger was just
it was such an interesting ride because
it it almost felt like at some points
after i don't know like the fourth or
fifth release date i was like i don't
know if this movie's ever gonna come out
was there a time where you guys felt
like this isn't gonna come out
yeah for sure i feel like i have a
friend who thinks it's not even real
he's like yeah
definitely a moment i just yeah there
was so much uncertainty it just
didn't you know i thought there's a good
chance that this
yeah there's a good chance that maybe
this never comes out and then
you know it's kind of nice to find out
oh no
you know disney gonna go ahead and it's
gonna come out
yeah and i feel like i i feel like the
excitement is even
bigger than it would have been if that
makes sense like what do you guys
what is the support from all the fans
meant to you guys throughout this whole
thing especially recently
i think it only grew exponentially it's
so weird they only get more and more
excited
and nearly feels like a marketing stunt
like you keep pushing this movie
and you get more people that weren't
even interested you know to begin with
now curious
like what's this movie that's been
delayed four times and the fans been
just
um you know incredibly patient and
loving
yeah well i mean these are characters
that
fans really love like the ones that know
them love them and this was originally
set up to be
a trilogy i believe so do you guys think
there's a space for these characters to
continue post-merger i mean
originally i always really like josh's
idea of having this
contain uh you know yeah truly concealed
yeah it's in its own world and when you
watch the film
it does feel very much you know in its
own
world and these characters feel yeah
very very contained so yeah that
question of you know
could you see them popping up in other
places
yeah i don't know how do you guys feel
about that
i think we all love our characters and
we all had a really good time i agree i
think
you know whatever happens we're kind of
open to it but if
this situation and what the world is
going through right now has taught us
anything it's let go
make the best of the situation that
you're in and just like
keep your feet on the ground planning is
nice for like
like i love to plan but i've now made
peace that my plans don't really mean
anything
right yeah marvel's an interesting beast
though it's like you know we never
thought we're going to see natalie
portman again and now she's going to be
thor
so it's like you never know things could
come up years later
oh whoa what really that's happening oh
yeah she's going to be
lady thor wow
that is sick
thank you for that for that i mean that
kind of made my day oh my god
charlie um stranger things is such a
huge fandom and ever
a lot of people know you as jonathan
byers so how was playing this new
character
a new challenge for you and what was it
like going from one massive fandom to
another
yeah um yeah for sure um i think the
challenge or or the the difference you
know
when i first started with stranger
things you know your
crea i mean you know the characters
written
but there is no expectation of what this
character is so
you know you go in there and you do your
version of this character and
then also there wasn't an expectation
for the show so it when it came out
you know that kind of fandom was was a
huge surprise where i think
the difference with when you take you
know you take on a a
marvel project or an excellent project
like you've mentioned
it is that expectation and it's also
you know also playing superhero i mean
you know that's very different
um but yeah and then and just
going through the process i think every
project you do you know is as is a
different
you know you know i like to come in a
different way and
uh yeah playing playing sam was was a
different
challenge for me for jonathan um for
sure
and um yeah and then just the last part
fandom
to to fandom uh you know stranger things
has a wonderful fandom when i've been
lucky enough to go all around the world
and experience that you know because of
this movie and our situation
right now we were doing this from zoom i
haven't really experienced the marvel
fandom but
i've seen it and i'm sure it's just as
big and
and kind of adored around the world so
you know i'm excited to kind of
hopefully experience a taste of what
that fandom is too
um because it's just nice to have such a
response
to these kind of loved you know pieces
of work
definitely and and speaking of response
henry yesterday i kind of gathered that
the brz
the comic-con in brazil was like a big
moment where you felt like oh we have
this big fandom it was really surreal i
mean we were in
um comic-con like elise and i and
josh and nate and we didn't realize that
we were on the
the biggest stage of the event and then
as soon as we walk on stage there's
just this massive scream i'm like nobody
knows who i am so it's
just you know outpour of love for the
character
and it was it was really weird because
you have to live up to these people's
expectations
you also hope that they're going to love
the movie they're going to love your
the work that you put into the movie um
but play brazilian it's something that
you know
i was talking to andy and charlie
yesterday i nearly forgot
for a second that i had like a little
line in portuguese in the movie
and when i when i saw that i was like
wow i'm also
playing brazilian in it and uh it's my
first time
on my so many of my first times is
happening with this movie
so it's pretty special well i am out of
time but anya i'm gonna
die for ilyana i can already tell um i
love her
so much so thank you guys so much for
your time i really appreciate it
no thank you thank you bye guys
get there off of here
are you crazy that thing will kill you
he's right it's magic
so no haley